what's your favorite sex position
i'm not i'm not answering that i am not
answering that
why not i don't want to explain loads to
you yeah and i didn't want to know
you could be just man on top women need
more
shut up mother look at my finger
what's your relationship like like
friends really like best friends really
very open don't hide anything
nothing really we're just nothing off
bad nothing nobody dreams no
no we talk very openly about any subject
whatsoever
are you anything you're going to be
surprised by there might be one or two
things
there might be because i've i've asked
him something and he said i'm not
telling you
and i don't like that because i want to
know the details
so we might just get it out here well
not that but the question
what are we talking about i don't know
when was the last time you had sex now
come on because
oh no yeah it's gonna be good come on
you're not gonna answer i asked you and
you wouldn't tell me
why aren't you answering what's the
problem with it
shut up
what's the most embarrassing thing i've
done in front of you probably one of
them
would have to be when you let people
motivate you
motorbike i forgot what that is
do you want to explain yeah i know i
think it's true what's motorboat
well it's where a person's face goes
into the oh i love that
you do it you yeah you do it in the pub
all the time well you've got to if
you've got a bit of cleavage
you've got to do it i've earned a
fortune with them
what excuse me people like flicking oh
they're freaking pound coins
you've told me about that before yeah i
it's where it remember a treat
if you switch genders for a day what's
the first thing you would do
obviously no well i'd want one out if
it's different for a woman
exactly that's why you just want it out
why don't you wing
well i can give different methods if you
get the chance you've got to get it
right you've already got a day
so i'm going to start with my two
fingers all right you do that man that's
right let me know how it goes
i knew you was gonna do it don't write
how i'm gonna start my day as a woman
okay
what's your favorite sex position
i'm not i'm not answering that i am not
answering that
oh my god i don't want to explain those
to you yeah and i didn't want to know
obviously helps
does it well what do you like then is it
a dog i'm not telling you what i like
they have a bad dog they have a back
shell a bit of a back shuffle
don't tell me you're just mad on top
stuff
i'm having too much fun with this this
is great oh
you can't be just man on top we didn't
need more
i'm not saying not just man on top right
now i'm not saying again
turn her around i'm not saying anything
shut up mother
look at my finger what age did you start
watching porn oh my god
i'll answer it i don't care um
i started collecting magazines at like
seven i know you did i bought your first
one
he was curious i thought what's the best
way to teach your son asking all these
questions curious i thought
you were having a look at that this is
true yeah
and do you think it helped yeah didn't
affect me no
made me more aware oh i went in and got
it off the top
yeah well no it started off with nuts
nuts yeah nuts and zoom you were a
regular on your nuts
you went very quiet reading them i don't
know why but i only said that
well yeah i know but you liked it yeah
it was right it was just interesting it
i think it helped you to gain respect
for a woman's body do you
i probably did yeah what's my most
annoying
habit i mean your driving can be a bit
annoying why i understand it
i do a good driver you're a good driver
right
but some things like you go on
roundabouts and don't bother checking
your mirrors
well i can't go ring it once lee you're
supposed to if there's a hot fireman
crossing the road you've got to check
them out first
don't even mention that story oh yeah
the fire run on her birthday was
on your birthday going through bristol
going across the traffic lights
the firemen stopped and then they had
the window down
and she was she flashed the fireman oh
have you ever done bum stuff bum stuff
please answer them
tried stuff not tried it but like i
had a hand a digit you're a matter of
face
no you just said i have okay i thought
it would have been like that
no but i've had a finger it's not
it was awful well they obviously didn't
do it right it was terrible i felt
violated did you
yeah what about giving it no why not
i've done it why not
if you want to i mean maybe in the
future at some point if it comes along
maybe i don't know but
right now no give it a go all right okay
thank you
do you think that i've been a good
parent i do think you've been a good
parent yeah
you haven't been strict which is no no
no no
you've been strict enough because i've i
kind of
the way you were strict it was kind of
like it worked
but also on the other hand it was like
sometimes i could have just done without
having any restrictions you've been a
very good parent
um i am proud of you oh good
got it give us give it a hug give it a
hug
look i laughed
do you stand up or sit down when you're
wiping your butt
i know what you really want to tell me
about that i really want it i really
want to
explain it like i know people say that
you shouldn't stand up because it
congeals and it's like peeling back like
like feeling about like i don't know
like a toasted chocolate with a nutella
on